hey everyone welcome back my name is
mahul and in this video we'll be
learning about why keys are required in
react when you're using those map or
filter kind of things and as you can see
i'm using a new format in this video so
this would this format with whiteboard
would be used more for more explanatory
and you know things which require me to
write down stuff so make sure you like
and subscribe to the channel if you want
to see more on such topics i'm going to
be taking suggestions from the comments
as well so make sure you comment down
the next topic we want to cover all
right so before we get into keys we need
to learn a little bit about what is
known as virtual dom in react and how
this is different from the real dom
which you have
so there are two aspects right here the
first one is dom and the second one is
virtual dom virtual dom is something
which react maintains inside javascript
inside the memory of javascript and this
dom is the real dom which appears on the
page that means any sort of change which
you do
to dom right here reflects directly on
the page however this virtual dom is a
fast javascript in memory representation
of almost all the elements you see in
the dom right and react does that why
the reason react does it is because it's
easier to manipulate and do batch
updates and do all sorts of stuff in
javascript than actually just
individually shipping every single
change to the real dom because that is
slow okay so now we have a little bit of
idea about
virtual dom let's just see how html and
rather dom
is formed right so let's say
you have a document
which looks something like this html
then you have a head then you have a
body tag and then you have a closing tag
all right so what dom does is that it
takes in your html input or html
document whatever you created index.html
for example and what it does is that it
converts it into a tree like structure
which you see above so maybe this is the
root or document node
right and then this is html and this is
head then this is body
and so on right so head could contain
title and meta tags body could contain
various other tags and so on the similar
thing react also does
react does it
for
the node which you provide right
so remember when you do a react dom dot
render you provide a
node like document or get element by id
and app or root so this is that root
node which you provide to react right so
that's how react also tries to maintain
an in-memory data structure or a tree of
the nodes okay now let's consider this
example where you try to construct this
format in html inside of react using map
right so what i mean is that you do
something like one two three dot map and
then render each of these lis
individually right now you might give
the name of the key you might say like
li key equal to
this element itself right now why do you
do that the reason you do that because
if you try to take a look here in this
example if i try to mimic it what's
happening here the tree would be
maintained something like this ul then
you have
basically three lis with you li li
and let's say another one
another li right so this these three lis
have their own text node information
which is one two and three right i'm
considering these are the keys right not
the values the values could be pretty
much anything right the values could be
anything these are the keys now let's
say
this was a state variable this variable
right here one two three was a state
variable and you updated this to four
five
three right so now what react has to do
is react has to go to this ul and say
that hey
you have new children now
right
and
once react tries to update this it also
has to inform dom right that render this
on the screen because this is in js
right this is in js like we mentioned
here and this has to convey this to dom
but what you will see here
because you have given unique keys which
are equal to their element value for
example in this case the new elements or
the new children are four five
and three right so this means react can
actually say
that only these two elements have
updated
and this element is still the same why
because it knows that this element has
not been updated because its key has not
been changed because its key was three
before and it's still three after the
update right because we are assuming the
value is the same as key in this example
now because of this react only has to
dispatch two updates to dom that means
it only has to update two lis on the
screen that means the browser has to
only work on updating the contents of
these two allies if you did not have a
key attribute here react has no idea
which element should it preserve or
which element should it destroy right so
if you don't have keys react would
destroy all these three allies
it will destroy all these three allies
and reconstruct all of them which is
potentially i mean it's the same effect
in this small example but if you think
about an example where you have hundreds
of item on the screen or something which
renders in thousands like a table list
or anything and you have to drag drop
certain elements then this becomes a
huge performance boost if you're doing
it right this performance boost can be
even optimized if you use memoization
with custom logic but keys is the first
step in order to let react know which
changes you want to actually change and
which changes you don't want to change
and this is the same reason react will
complain very loudly if you have two
elements with the same keys so let's say
if you had another three here and you do
this then this will be a huge warning in
the console that hey you have two
elements with the same keys why because
now react cannot distinguish if it
happens to be that if you have
manipulated certain elements or certain
things then you know which element has
it it has to remove and which element it
has to keep that is why it is very
important that you have unique keys
whenever you are using a key attribute
with react one more common convention
which people use is that they say one
two three dot map for example and then
the element comma index which is their
index in the map and then they specify
the index
as the key
now this is bad this is bad until and
unless you're definitely sure that this
data will remain static for example if
you are creating a faq from array then
this is fine because you know that
nobody's really you know you're not
providing the functionality to drag and
drop faq but this index thing is bad why
because the moment you change this
element array the keys are gonna change
all of the keys are going to change and
react although will not complain to you
that this is not unique because index is
unique but react has no idea that some
elements might have
not required a re-render right so this
is a case where react will not complain
to you that this is a bad practice but
it is right if possible if this is an
object you should have an el dot id
something like that which allows react
to
just stick with a value which it knows
for sure is unique this is a super
important optimization tip and react and
i hope you understood something from
this video i tried out this new format
let me know what you think about having
videos like this but yep if you like
this make sure you like the video that's
all about react and keys in the basic
sense that is all for this one i'm gonna
see you in the next video really soon
[Music]
you